shark boy and lava girl are back for an
avengers style sequel but when they're
captured by alien invaders a group of
super-powered kids including their
daughter guppy have to come together to
try and rescue them
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video we're diving into the ending of we
can be heroes
to reveal all the secret clues you
missed that set up the movie's big twist
obviously spoilers ahead so take care we
can be heroes initially tricks us into
thinking we're watching a pretty typical
alien invasion movie where superheroes
will save the day
however at the end of the film we learn
this has all been a giant ruse
the aliens aren't here to openly attack
us but to secretly support us
by training the next generation of
superheroes in the awesome power of
teamwork so that the super kids can take
over from their parents and fix the
earth's many problems as soon as
possible
for their plan to work the aliens
infiltrated both the government
and heroics hq but it wasn't just the
president's name
neil and army which is i'm an alien
spelled backwards that pointed to the
movie's twist
ending a big clue to the surprise twist
was also hidden in the name of the
alien's home planet which was called
ogima
if you spell a gamer backwards it turns
out to be amigo which is a spanish word
for friend
a message from the supreme commander of
the aliens that we are from the planet
ogima
so the fact the aliens were really here
to help us humans rather than hummus was
predicted right from the beginning of
the movie
interestingly writer director robert
rodriguez also indulged in a bit of
backwards naming in the original
sharkboy and lavagirl movie
calling an unfinished robot character
tobor which is robot spelled in reverse
even before we find out the name of the
alien planet though there's another huge
hint to the film's finale when missy
sees miracle guy being wheeled into an
ambulance after the movie's opening
alien attack
and in an effort to reassure her and
stop her worrying her dad tells her
that is just a training exercise
probably uh
a what if in fact it turns out that
everything missy and her super powered
pals go through after this in the movie
is indeed a big training exercise
organized by the aliens to ready the
kids to step into their parents super
shoes and save the world
there are also several telltale signs as
soon as we meet ahold that there's much
more to her than meets the eye
first of all she's not dressed like any
of the other kids who are all wearing
t-shirts jeans and other casual clothes
in contrast to her smarter white blouse
and black trousers
and that seems appropriate because after
all she is the alien supreme commander
on top of that her name ocho is a
spanish word for i
and can also mean insight all of which
fits her character perfectly as she's
all about
vision and foreshadowing what's going to
happen drawing things on her tablet
which later come
true but that's not all the word oho can
also be used in spanish to warn someone
to watch out or look out which is also
fitting as ocho isn't what she appears
to be
she's not a human girl she's actually an
alien
i love these little clues and extra
layers of meaning that mexican-american
robert rodriguez gives the film by
including spanish words like this
and the fact he continues to cast
diversely including lots of latinx
actors as he's done on many of his
previous projects by the way if you were
watching like a hawk
during the scene in the tunnels you
might just have caught the picture ahord
drove herself with her alien tentacles
on display which flashed by
in a millisecond as missy was swiping
past on ocho's tablet
and there was another sneaky clue that
it was ocho who was really in charge of
the aliens all along when the kids
discovered the president on the alien
mothership and overheard him discussing
the takeover
how long before the takeover begins
according to the supreme commander
less than an hour ever wonder why we
bother with all this but she already
knows how it's going to turn out
that's a reference to oho's ability to
see the future and a clue that she's the
one really giving the orders
did you also notice ms granada's rather
odd exaggerated mana from the start
which was perhaps a clue to her alien
nature
for example when she enters a control
room at hq
she walks more like a model sashaying
down a catwalk
and then there's a slightly strange way
she often holds her hands out to the
sides
almost as if she's either performing a
dance in a musical or trying to keep her
balance
maybe that's because of the massive
alien tentacle she's having to hide in
her human disguise
that the new heroics kids can succeed
where the adults failed is also cleverly
emphasized throughout the movie
for example the many butterflies dotted
around missy's room right at the
beginning of the film
symbolize the fact that she and the
other kids represent a new beginning a
fresh chance to get things right
while the rainbow on guppy's necklace
sends a subtle message from the start
that these super kids are humanity's
hope for a better world as oho confirms
at the end of the movie
this new generation of heroes is all
about teamwork
rather than squabbling amongst
themselves like their parents
and to accentuate just how different
they are to the previous generation the
new heroics also have an
entirely different look gone are the
colourful costumes and hard to see out
of masks
often favored by superheroes including
many of their mums and dads such as
shark boy and lava girl
all superheroes have costumes pads fake
muscles
tons of useless buckles underwear on the
outside
masks you could barely see out of that's
why they were able to pick out our
parents so easily
we have to blend in instead those highly
visible costumes are replaced by more
practical uniforms in muted colors
so what are we supposed to be looking at
the future there are also masses of
shark boy and lava girl easter eggs in
the movie
which you can discover in my other video
tap here to watch that or follow the
link in the video description
so what do you think about the ending of
we can be heroes and would you
like to see more sequels let me know in
the comments below
tap left for all of my we can be heroes
easter eggs or tap right to watch
something else you're sure to like
and if you enjoyed this video a thumbs
up is hugely appreciated
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers